oh I'm chip hailstone and I've been
living off and on here since about 1993
I've been in the region for 25 years
we're in Norfolk Alaska along the cove
buck River has about 680 people here
they're mostly in you pack these folks
are on a good spot on the river for
fishing and advantageous places right
above the ocean not too far away we're
on a delta to a large large river and
it's a very resource rich area we got
the Sun returning is 28 below right now
we're kind of an isolated village like
most of them on this region are and no
fences there's no roads there's no speed
limits there's no help you really need
it you got to do it for yourself these
are my neighbors have neighbors all
around after a while you pretty much
know everybody another name of their dog
some of our to the office works over
here our water plant and there's our
water tank they purify the water and
then run through a system they have to
eat it it's a mix for $160 a month water
bill but I like learning water I went up
all right okay Matt count how many years
I've been without water okay when he
came along they're all pretty happy that
this is our school this is where
children go from kindergarten to twelfth
grade and a lot of different
opportunities that they have in here and
they get to so and they get to learn all
kinds of ways that they can utilize
materials around us to make a living so
the schools not only teaching them
modern Western ways it also keeps them
up on ways that still apply today that
they developed from tradition long ago
so I like it I think these guys do a
really good job
there's the house my wife was born in
even though 29 people would be living in
there they wouldn't all be there they
just were fishing or they were at camp
or they said so much stuff going on
there really well organized family and
they they kept it to the same way that
they'd been doing it you know family
wise clan wise for thousands of years
anyway this this part of town that we're
approaching is considered uptown and
most of its abandoned up there you know
if it's not really old than it's
definitely gone off the cliff already
and there's people that have actively
removing the houses up there right now
and recycling the wood and it's just the
old development going to a new
development this is the co buck River
this is the new zurich channel of the co
buck river were in a delta and we have a
lot of Slough as an inter connecting
lakes and streams and in the springtime
when this ice breaks up and it floods up
we have access to just all kinds of
crazy places and when the water goes
down we're stuck to the main channels
again but it's a very dynamic place
there's a lot of fish there's a lot of
waterfowl in the summer in the
wintertime there's different fishes that
come in and replace them and this place
makes an excellent feeding ground for
caribou so when the caribou actually do
get into the Delta they tend to stay
there's lots of grass that they like to
eat around these lakes and they can also
- into trees quickly and get away from
wolves but then the Wolves can get away
from us - so we like to hunt them on
open land this is a really good place
this is where the river meets the sea
right over there at the ocean and right
up there is the way to the interior so
it's a good place to be